виявляється вся команда президента - це
п'ять-шість менеджерів Ну я наївний
думав що команда президента воюючої
країни - це Всі ми що всі хто допомагає
працює в першу чергу військові в першу
чергу е дипломати в першу чергу ті хто
забезпечують економічну складову Він же
сам говорить що на кожного солдата має
бути там шість чи скільки тамн сказав
людей які це
забезпечують А ну потім виявляється що
все впирається в п'ять-шість менеджерів
може він мав на увазі найближче коло
якесь Ну Вибачте питання було дещо про
інше І він виявилося що от вця команда -
це 5-6ість людей а ви там маломалолюді
ідіть собі там ідіть займайтесь